[Music]
we have had men yell at us like oh my
God girls in skates but then
we have like people saying like oh my
God I want to roller skate like I used
to roller skate I haven't seen skates in
years you know so that's not actually
the rental came up about because people
are like where can I rent skates
skate all the time we're like uh Red's
Escape yeah we have rental skates yeah
we get outdoor friendly rental skates
like if you wanted a cruiser cruise
around it's very what is the word we're
nostalgic yeah absolutely it is a
Nostalgia thing like I feel like the
biggest thing we get especially when
we're dressing our tube socks in our 70s
gears we see a lot of people that are
like oh my God that brings me back so
you can customize skates by changing out
the wheels you can change out the toe
stops and then if you really want to get
into it you can also change out the
plate and
[Music]
there's really endless possibilities of
customization that you can make with any
role
[Music]
I I do love my Moxie lollies like I love
this so these are one of my favorite
steaks I have like six pairs by the way
but this is one of my favorite
antique is what's up they if you look at
the boot everything ankle support the
flat ground everything it just so Derby
friendly and they're pretty you know
like I used to Park Skate in my old
Antics and I did Derby so it's very it
translates well
oh